it all starts with an idea an idea turns
into a business and that business
creates data what if you don't have the
right product connecting the data in the
cloud with your data on-site that is not
an option
introducing IBM clouds direct link
designed for businesses that need to
manage data and to scale between a
remote network and their IBM cloud
environments there is a version of
direct link that is perfectly tailored
to your business and needs for hybrid
workloads Multi cloud environments or
frequent data transfers we introduced
IBM cloud direct link exchange direct
link exchange allows customers
co-located in neutral data centers to
leverage a cloud exchange provider to
deliver connectivity to IBM cloud for
datacenter to datacenter connectivity or
customer premise to data center
connectivity there is direct link
connect IBM clouds direct link Connect
enables multi cloud connectivity and
offers flexible bandwidth options while
providing a lower cost entry point for
IBM thousand etwork customers if you
deal with hybrid cloud workloads or have
high performance workloads requiring low
latency we recommend IBM cloud direct
link dedicated this solution allows you
to terminate a single tenant fiber cross
connect into your own IBM cloud private
network or if you're working with
non-standard technologies need to
leverage existing IT investments or need
your hardware co-located near an IBM
cloud datacenter dedicated hosting might
be right for you with dedicated hosting
the connection point is adjacent to an
IBM cloud datacenter which provides the
low latency and high throughput IBM
cloud also offers customizable
colocation services combined with direct
link dedicated with this solution no
matter your business needs no matter how
you grow or evolve IBM cloud direct link
has the solution visit IBM com to learn
more
you
[Music]